[Música]
el síndrome de down es una alteración es
genética por material genético extra en
el cromosoma 21 esa información trae el
desafío de la discapacidad pero como
veremos discapacidad no es lo mismo que
incapacidad merecen las personas con
down como cualquier otra persona
igualdad de oportunidades respeto y
también reconocimiento a los aportes que
hacen en nuestras comunidades Hoy es el
día para hablar de ese tema porque es el
Día Mundial del síndrome de down y me
acompaña en el estudio Sara Valentina
niño ella tiene 21 años es estudiante de
periodismo en la academia ava en
Colombia y también estudia técnica vocal
e inglés pertenece además al grupo de
autogestores de Ash down Colombia y es
una mujer síndrome de down Sara
bienvenida France 24 y a directo América
gracias por la invitación No gracias a
usted por aceptarnos la invitación hoy
para conmemorar el día de Internacional
del down el mundo sin embargo sa no está
hecho para las personas con down el
problema es el down o el problema es el
mundo que no es incluyente y no se
adapta para todos Que el mundo no está
incluyente bueno y cómo lo ha
experimentado usted bueno digamos yo en
mi caso
volviéndome digamos al pasado hay muchas
digamos hay muchas cosas que
me hacían como el rechazo sí digamos
Cuando entré al bachiller
todos los colegios le cerraban las
puertas a mi mamá
pues me sentía como mal por eso sí me
sentía muy mal también
a lo largo de mi vida Pues he sentido
digamos cuando entera sexo
principalmente me rechazaban Sí como que
ellos mis compañeros se hacían con otros
amigos y siempre me dejan sola en los
descansos Claro pero
eso no debe ser así no Y sobre todo
usted Sara como como cualquier otra
persona demostrado que puede más el
esfuerzo y el interés por estudiar por
educarse por comunicarse háblenos un
poco acerca de sus estudios en
periodismo bueno
el periodismo es muy chévere Ya que pues
se puede expresarse delante una cámara
estudiar lo que uno más le gusta
Usted cree Sara que es importante que
haya espacios diferentes para las
personas con down o sería mejor que
existieran espacios en los que todos
pudiéramos estar incluidos y Y cómo son
esos espacios Bueno a mí sí me gustaría
que nos incluyeran más a las personas
con síndrome down porque nosotros
podemos
salir adelante Sí también
somos capaces de muchas cosas
Es normal que una persona con tenga más
desafíos a la hora de enfrentar un
proceso de aprendizaje sin embargo el
proceso de aprendizaje puede ser
Igualmente difícil o incluso doloroso
para cualquier persona pero también es
un camino que está lleno de
satisfacciones cómo ha sido para usted
el proceso de acceder a la educación a
lo largo de su vida
Bueno entonces le cambio la pregunta
cómo cómo ves esa sensación de estarse
educando todo el tiempo le pongo un
ejemplo está estudiando inglés Está
estudiando periodismo es una vocera hace
parte de conferencias y de charlas todo
el tiempo
no pues se siente muy chévere se siente
que
se siente que digamos las opiniones de
cada uno de cada uno que tiene síndrome
down son muy importantes y saber
Escuchar lo primero que es saber
escuchar a las demás personas y no le ha
pasado a Sara que yendo por la calle la
gente tiende por ejemplo a abrazarla o
hablarle como Si usted fuera una bebé
como si fuera todavía una niña pequeña
Por qué No deberíamos hacer ese tipo de
acercamientos con las personas con down
y tratarlos como si fueran bebés
mira que bueno si he escuchado a varias
personas diciendo esas cosas pero mira
que yo siento que no nos deben de tratar
así nos deben tratar como personas común
y corrientes y entender además Sara que
la persona con síndrome de down no es
una persona que tenga problemas sino que
tiene necesidades como cualquier otra
persona de que necesitan ser satisfechas
cómo le va usted desenvolviéndose en su
día a día
pues me
voy bien si digamos en esa parte
[Música]
digamos que esas cosas
Ojalá que las opiniones de todos sean
escuchadas
bueno Sara Cómo no debemos tratar a las
personas con Down
Cómo así nosotros deberíamos tratarlos
con igualdad Ese es el mensaje que usted
defiende y que tiene derecho a estar en
todos los espacios Entonces qué errores
cometemos las personas al creer o
subestimar a las personas con dona
digamos que nos tratan de
Bueno le voy a decir así como de
Pobrecitos que no sabemos nada en No al
contrario sabemos muchas cosas y todas
las opiniones que digamos
también
me gustaría digamos saber esas cosas
porque
digamos ser una mujer con síndrome down
no digamos es bonito pero al mismo
tiempo me tiene que tratar como si fuera
una persona común y corriente
cuando se habla con acerca de las
personas con síndrome de down muchas
veces en términos médicos se habla de
que se sufre o se padece el síndrome de
down usted está de acuerdo el síndrome
de down es algo que se sufre No claro
que no se sufre Qué es lo que pasa
cuando uno tiene síndrome de down se
siente
no se siente normal tenemos una
condición Sí pero no O sea no influye en
la en el desarrollo
académico ni en el desarrollo personal y
en ese sentido podríamos decir que el
síndrome de down es una enfermedad
porque todavía mucha gente hoy habla de
del síndrome como si fuera una persona
que está en mal estado de salud o que
tiene unos síntomas eso es verdad no no
es verdad Entonces
o sea el síndrome de down no es una
enfermedad lo que lo que lo que nosotros
tenemos es una alteración genética como
tú nos decías es una alteración genética
que
Pues que es una casualidad sí es una
casualidad que al final puede ser una
feliz coincidencia de la vida y bueno
nosotros quisimos invitarla hoy Sara
para destacar lo importante que es que
ustedes y todos podamos Vivir de manera
independiente y como adultos íntegros
sin embargo muchas veces pasa sobre todo
en países como Colombia o en América
Latina que todavía vemos a los
ciudadanos da un de la mano de sus papás
o de sus cuidadores cuando eso no es
necesario son personas independientes
Usted qué opina de eso no que Claro que
sí somos independientes Pero hay algunas
cosas que digamos
en mi caso me sobreprotegen digamos en
el manejo del dinero en el transporte
público entonces
hay ciertas ocasiones en que uno no
digamos que nadie se sobrepase con uno
como lo tenemos que luchar todos y
además todas las mujeres Sara finalmente
le quería preguntar por esas tareas de
la vida que a veces puede que sean un
poco más difíciles puede que cuesten más
pero igual no es ningún problema no no
hay ningún problema por eso es que
aprendemos de una manera diferente y más
sobre eso le quería preguntar por
ejemplo el proceso para aprender a leer
para aprender a escribir para hablar
cómo cómo es eso en carne propia
digamos que
nosotros digamos aprendemos bueno
tenemos nuestra condición pero nosotros
aprendemos de una manera diferente a las
demás personas sí digamos que
un niño sí que no tenga discapacidad
aprende un ritmo digamos lento o puede
ser muy rápido en cambio las personas
con síndrome down o con alguna
discapacidad aprendemos de una manera
diferente nuestras opiniones son
diferentes Si
herramientas son diferentes Entonces eso
lo que nos cuesta a veces nos cuesta
digamos algunas personas no se les
cuesta hacer eso pero no es algo que
surgió y pues toca aceptar así como
somos no pero me gusta lo que dice
porque es algunas personas nos cuesta y
algunas personas nos cuestan muchísimas
cosas no todos somos buenos para todo y
no todos tenemos los mismos talentos
usted conoce Sara a Pablo Pineda Sí
bueno entonces Pablo Pineda para
nuestros televidentes que no lo conocen
probablemente es una figura muy
importante de la representación da un es
uno de los primeros licenciados en
Europa en hacer conferencias es escritor
es actor además da constantemente
cátedra sobre lo que es vivir con down y
lo que es existir con down de manera
incluyente él siempre habla de de un
mensaje para las personas down y es
mirarse por dentro y entender cuáles son
talentos usted ha hecho ese ejercicio
Claro que sí digamos en mi caso
mi sueño es ser periodista entonces
me gusta todo lo que tiene que ver con
la farándula entonces
por ahí puede por ahí pueden ver pues
una entrevista que hice con Arelys
henada si me está escuchando le mando un
fuerte abrazo y no pues me siento como
muy emocionada por eso pues es un gusto
dar a conocerla Gracias por visitarnos
en directo a América Le deseo un feliz
día y le deseo que pueda seguir por la
vida con igualdad como se lo merece
igual que todos Muchas gracias por la
invitación y no pues agradecida con la
vida por estar acá sabe que un último
mensaje le quiero pedir para las
personas con down que nos están viendo
los niños las niñas Los Adolescentes y
jóvenes con down bueno el mensaje que
les quiero decir es que luchen por sus
sueños que lean que sean disciplinados
que sean curiosos investiguen lean Que
se preparen porque somos capaces de
muchas cosas y que así sea muchas
gracias a ustedes y a nuestros
televidentes en directo a América sigan
con nosotros ella regresamos después de
una muy pequeña pausa
[Música]